Is making your own butter better?
I think it is, but
there is certain requirements
for it to be better than store bought butter.
Like buying regular
low grade cream from Walmart and blending it does create butter,
but it's gonna be the exact same quality of butter
that you get from Walmart,
where there's nothing wrong with that butter.
I still buy that sometimes and I use it when I'm baking a lot.
If you want better butter,
you're gonna have to get better cream to create that butter.
We have our own Jersey dairy cow,
so she has very high fat content in her milk.
And this is raw cream, so it hasn't been pasteurized,
has not been homogenized. So we milk the cow,
we put it in the fridge,
and the next day the cream will separate on top of the milk.
Then I just scoop the cream off top of the milk
before the kids drink it, cause they don't like it full fat in that way.
It's just kinda too chunky.
As you shake up the cream,
it's kinda like got chunks of cream in it,
and I actually don't mind that,
but the kids just don't like the texture, so.
And I use the cream for my coffee.
I absolutely love it. So right here
I'm using ice water to press the butter
to make sure all the buttermilk is out of the butter.
Because if you leave buttermilk inside the butter,
it will Go rancid fast because the buttermilk goes rancid or sour,
so you'll start having, like,
a sour butter taste. And the water from my faucet comes out warm,
cause we're in Georgia, even on the cold setting.
So I do use an ice water bath.
And then I'm gonna salt the butter.
Um, some recipes,
I don't like to use salted butter,
but if I want it to preserve,
I'm gonna have to put some salt in it.
Here I'm using a butter crock.
This stays on the counter.
This has got water in it, so it creates a water seal.
So this will stay on the counter.
I can use this for up to a week,
and I can use it for anything I want.
Soft butter on the rest of this butter,
I'm gonna salt it. Even though I'm gonna put it in the fridge,
I'm gonna salt it still
because it's got lots of moisture in it from washing it,
and it might still have a little bit of buttermilk in it.
So I'm gonna use that salt to preserve
and soak up any moisture that's in the butter
to stop it from going sour faster.
I want it to last, um,
I think it normally last about a month in the fridge.
I've not really had butter go sour in the fridge.
I use it fast enough. If you want to preserve it longer,
you could wrap it in this paper,
put it in a ziploc, Bag and put it in the freezer.
So from the cream I had for my cow,
I have now got some butter and buttermilk to make some biscuits.